this is such a fun journey and adventure
of a ride no this really is i'm so
excited just to watch it with an
audience tonight it's a thrill i know
and i think audiences are going to be
like oh my gosh i'm having a 13 going on
30 reunions
yes definitely
[Music]
are you okay
i should have talked wrong oh i'm
getting old
no you're not because that means i
well a fun moment with mark on set it
was so lovely it was really comforting
to be together again i i didn't i don't
think either of us realized how much we
needed it and how great it would feel
but we were together
in this movie in the beginning of our
careers and making the movie
specifically was so special and then
it's meant so much to so many people
since then which has been such a gift so
we've kind of been woven through each
other's lives but without the benefit of
really
being together and it just felt it felt
like we were picking up where we left
off you're wearing my dad's watch
this watch
you're me
[Music]
that's classified but yes
that once was in the spirit of the film
the adam project look you have ryan
reynolds character has the opportunity
to go back and visit his older self for
his younger self and i feel like a
recent instagram post of yours you threw
back to 20 years ago being on the cover
of a magazine celebrating promoting
alias as the spirit of the film what
would you tell that young lady 20 years
ago about what lies ahead in her career
oh i mean i wouldn't even talk to her
about her career um i would have a lot
to chat with her about
but no i would just tell her to grab
hold of every opportunity and moment and
um and including the times that you get
to go home and be with your friends from
high school and your parents and sisters
and um but you know
i don't know i would just tell her it's
going to be okay just keep forging ahead
i also love seeing you know the theme of
parenting and parenting skills and
styles and everything like that your
character is really wanting to hone in
on our kid look just think about your
future the decisions you make are
affecting your future so is that your
kind of your speech as a parent yourself
are you saying hey you got to make the
good grades you got to behave well you
got to focus now i don't think that i
think that my character is under a
particular amount of you know a very
specific kind of stress she's grieving
the loss of her husband her son is
grieving the loss of his father she is
stressed beyond belief and she doesn't
have support she doesn't have support to
hold her up and to help her
have a deep breath before
dealing with an unruly child who keeps
getting in trouble at school so she
reacts um i don't have any judgment on
her but no i'm lucky enough to have the
kind of support where i don't need to
react like that to my kids